ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA OUR QUE HAN. BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA BRO BURKE CALDERON. ZERO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN DAVID CHIU
CHOI KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY DE EGGMAN
FLORA FONG USER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GLORIA GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LEVINE
LIMON. LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS LOOSE REEBOKS
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH STONE TING
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS. A CORN
IS PRESENT WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND PATTY ACOSTA. EVER
NOTION. PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
MOMENT OF REFLECTION. EVERY
SINGLE DAY EACH OF US OUR LIVES
ARE CREATING RIPPLES THAT TOUCH
IN IMPACT THE LIVES OF OTHERS.
WE CREATE RIPPLES WITH EVERY
WORD SPOKEN WITH EVERY DECISION
WE MAKE IN EVERY ACTION THAT WE
TAKE. THE REBELS AFFECTING
OTHERS ALSO CREATED BY WHAT WE
DO NOT DO AND WHAT WE DO NOT
SAY. FOR EVEN ARE IN ACTION IS
AN ACTION IN EVEN OUR SILENCE
WILL RIPPLE AND HAVE
CONSEQUENCES. AS REVEREND
DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING WOULD
SAY. OUR LIVES BEGIN TO END THE
DAY WE BECOME SILENT ABOUT
THINGS THAT MATTER. IN THE END
WE WILL REMEMBER NOT THE WORDS
OF OUR ENEMIES BUT THE SILENCE
OF OUR FRIENDS. NO MORE
AMENABLE TO WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS. THANK
YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO AND SHE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE THANK YOU MEMBERS ARE
PUT TO RIGHT HAND OVER YOUR
HEART READY BEGIN. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO. THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. IS. THANK
YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED. MOVING
TO THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY JANUARY
EIGHTH TWENTY TWENTIES HUMAN AT
SEVEN AM CALDERON MOVES AND
MISS YOUR CHANCE SECONDS THAT
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE TO BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES
FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS DALY MULLIN
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK SILVA BRO.
CHEN IN DEEP. AND FOR MATERNITY
LEAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES.
RIGHT YEAH. MISTER CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED PROMOTIONS THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MAYES AND MEDINA TO SPEAK ON IN
A GERMAN IN MEMORY TODAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR I AM GIVING A ONE DAY
NOTICE TO REMOVE FILE ITEM A.
NINE A. NINE A. B. THIRTEEN
FIFTY SIX TING FROM AN ACTIVE
FILE. THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
THERE IS A LIST OF VETOED BILLS
AT THE DESK THAT AUTHORS ARE
REQUESTING TO. BE STRICKEN FROM
THE FILE. I ASK THAT THE
READING CLERK READ THE LIST AND
THAT WE STRIKE THOSE ITEMS.
FROM THE FILE THE CLERK WILL
READ. PHONE TWO SO WE BILL FOR
FORTY NINE GALLAGHER PROBLEM
FOR SOME LEGAL SEVEN SEVENTY
SIX KALRA FATHER FIVE CYNICAL
TO NINETY THREE RUBIO FOLLOW
HIM SIX SENATE BILL TWELVE
TWENTY SEVEN OBERNOLTE. BOTTOM
SEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
FORTY NINE MAIENSCHEIN FOLLOW
HIM TENANTS ILLEGAL SIXTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT CARILLO FOLLOW HIM
TWELVE SOME LEGAL THREE NINETY
FOUR OBERNOLTE. FONG FOURTEEN
SOME AGO FIVE NINETY FOUR SALAS
FOLLOWED FIFTEEN A SINGLE SEVEN
SEVENTY THREE GONZALEZ PROBABLY
SIXTEEN SO WE WILL SIGN SIXTY
SEVEN SMITH BOTTOM SEVENTEEN A
SINGLE TEN EIGHTY FIVE MCCARTY.
BOTTOM TWENTY ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE SEVENTY TWO VOEPEL FIVE
TWENTY ONE SOME AGO FIVE TWENTY
FOUR BIGELOW BOTTOM TWENTY TWO
SOME PEOPLE A SIXTY NINE
CUNNINGHAM FONG AND TWENTY FOUR
SO WE WILL EIGHT OH THREE
GIPSON. FOLLOW HIM TWENTY FIVE
AWESOME AGO NINE TWENTY SEVEN
JONES SAWYER BOTTOM TWENTY SIX
SO WE WILL TWELVE TWELVE LEVINE
PROBLEM TWENTY SEVEN ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN FIFTY EIGHT RAMOS
PROBLEM TWENTY EIGHT THE BILL
FIVE FIFTY SIX CARILLO. BOTTOM
TWENTY NINE SO WE WILL TEN
EIGHTY SIX POWER QUE AND
PROBLEM THIRTY SOME GOAL OF
NINETY FIVE OLD ON FIVE THIRTY
ONE CYNICAL THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO
BERMAN FIVE THIRTY TWO. SOME
PEOPLE FORTINO SEVEN FRIEDMAN
FALLEN THIRTY THREE SOME AGO
FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
THREE OF US AWESOME PHAM THIRTY
FOR SOME PEOPLE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN LEVINE FOLLOWING
THIRTY FIVE CYNICAL TWENTY
THREE BURKE FIVE THIRTY SIX
SOME LEGAL TWENTY EIGHT
OBERNOLTE. I'M THIRTY SEVEN
SENATOR ONE ANYONE GONZALEZ
PINE THIRTY CYNICAL TO FIFTY
EIGHT JONES SAWYER BY IMPORTING
MINUTES AGO FOURTEEN THE PINE
FOR THE SINGLE THREE FORTY ONE.
FORTY ONE ASSEMBLY RULE THREE
FOR FOUR QUIRK SILVA. FORTY TWO
SEVERAL THREE. FORTY SOME FOR
SEVENTY SIX WERE. OUT OF FORTY
THREE ASSEMBLY RULE. IN
ARAMBULA. I'M FORTY. SO WE WILL
SIX. BOTTOM FORTY SO ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE FIFTY FLOOR FONG
FORTY SEVEN. FIVE EIGHTY NINE.
PART OF EIGHT SIX FOR CABLE
BOND FOR ASSEMBLY UCCEED IN.
LIVING FATHER FIFTY WIGGLE SO
THIRTY THREE QUIRK BOTTOM
FIFTY. SUMMER OF ONE OF THE-
BOTTOM FIFTY TWO SINGLES SEVEN
REYES FATHER FIFTY THREES. SOME
TWO TO. BEFORE SOME AGO A TWO.
FATHER PRETTY FIVE BILL A YOU
DID I'M- BOTTOM FIFTY SIX
ASSEMBLY WROTE NINETY ONE BURKE
FIVE FIFTY SEVEN. BILL A NINETY
NINE WOULD. BE A SO WE'RE GOING
TWENTY. OUR FATHER NINE BILL NO
ANY THREE THIS AREA. BOTTOM
SIXTY ASSEMBLY WILL NINE CABLE
BOND. ONE A SYMBOL TO FOURTEEN.
PROBLEMS IT TO SEE. AN EIGHTY
FOR ME. MAYBE ONE LIMON BOTTOM
SIXTY FOUR SO MIDDLE TWELVE
THIRTY THREE SMALL. BOTTOM
SIXTY FIVE. SO PEOPLE TALK TO
ROBERT RIVAS PROBLEM SIXTY SIX
ASSEMBLY WILL TO READY TO. OUR
SIX SEVEN SO. PORT TO.
AGUIAR-CURRY BOTTOM SIX EIGHT
ASSEMBLY WILL THIRTEEN NINETY
THREE. BOTTOM SIXTY NINE
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN. WILL BE
BOTTOM SEVENTIES BILL FOR SIXTY
SIX OR- BOTTOM SEVENTY ONE
ASSEMBLY FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
GLORIA PROBLEMS OF TWO SOME.
FORTY SEVENTY EIGHT CARILLO.
BOB SEVENTY THREE IS A BILL SIX
NO FIVE TING BOTTOMS UP FORCING
SOME PEOPLE SIXTEEN SO SEVEN
WAY. BOTTOM SEVENTY FIVE
ASSEMBLY BILL. TO TWO FLOOR
FONG SEVENTY SIX ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN. PROBLEM SEVENTY SO
ASSEMBLY ONE SIX SIX A- BOTTOM
SEVENTY. SOME OF ONE NINETY
SEVEN WEBER. BOTTOM SEVENTY
NINE SOME BILL TO ALLOW COLDER
FONG EIGHTIES TO GO TO A THREE.
A FATHER ONCE WE WILL TURN A
FOUR ONE. FIVE EIGHTY TWO SOME
THREE SEEKING CHU SOME FOLLOW
EIGHTY THREE SO WE WILL. FORTY
FOUR CALDERON FIVE A FOUR
SIMILAR THREE FORTY SIX COOPER.
EIGHTY FIVE SOME AGO FIFTIES
WHEN IS THERE. FIVE EIGHTY SIX
SIMPLE. FIX WATER GARCIA BOTTOM.
EIGHTY BLEVINS. FIVE CONSULT
PROBLEM EIGHTY NINE AS FIVE
TWELVE TO PROBLEM NINETY SOME
REAL TWO KALRA FIVE NINE ONE
SOME SIX FIVE KALRA FIVE NINETY
TWO SINGLES THIRTY EIGHT GRAY
FIVE NINETY THREE SO WE WILL
EIGHTY ONE GONZALEZ NINETY FIVE
IS BILL EIGHT FORTY TWO WILL
KNOWN NINETY FOUR SOME PEOPLE'S
THIRTY MAINS FIVE NINETY
ASSEMBLY EIGHT FORTY EIGHT GRAY
PROBABLY NINETY SEVEN SO PEOPLE
EIGHTY FIVE. BY NINETY EIGHT
ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY HOLDEN
WHILE I'M NOT NINE IS A WE WILL
NOT PORK BY MORE HUNT SIMPLY GO
NITES SO BOTTOM ONE A ONE BILL
THIRTY SO AND WE ARE BOTTOM ONE
OF SOME TENS OF FIVE OH BOND
ONE OH THREE SO WE GO TO NINETY
TWO JONES SAWYER I'M ONE OF FOR
SOME WE WILL LIVE FIFTY QUICK
ON A ONE FIVE ASSEMBLY LEVENSON
FIVE WERE FALL IN ONE OF SIX
ASSEMBLY ROLLED BEFORE GLORIA
BY ONE OF SEVEN PEOPLE TWELVE
FORTY MELENDEZ MULLIN WANT TO
EAT SOME THIRTEEN OH SEVEN
RUBIO. I'M NINETY SEVEN
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE TO BOTTOM
ONE TENNIS ILLEGAL FOURTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN CHEN BOTTOM ONE
ELEVEN SOME WIGGLE FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN FREAK FRIEDMAN BOTTOM
ONE TWELVE ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN NINETY RUBIO BOTTOM ONE
THIRTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
THIRTEEN O'DONNELL BOTTOM ONE
FOURTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
EIGHTY ONE DOLLARS BOTTOM ONE
FIFTEEN ASSEMBLY WILL SIXTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT CALDERON BOTTOM
ONE SIXTEEN SYMBOLS YOU KNOW TO
THREE OF US BOTTOM ONE
SEVENTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
TWENTY SEVEN WEBER AND A SALUTE
FOLLOWED ONE TINA SO MAYBE.
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SIX. THANK YOU.
OUT OF. MEMBERS WE HAVE AGAIN
WITH US THE FLOOR TODAY I LIKE
TO WALK FORMER CONGER GO MAY TO
OUR FLOOR THE GIVE A WARM.
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE. THE SECOND READING FILE
ITEM. THE FILE ITEM ONE WILL
PASS THE RETAIN FILE ITEMS ONE
NINETEEN THROUGH ONE TWENTY
FIVE. SECOND READING
PERCHLORATE SO WE WILL THREE
TWENTY FIVE MINUTES. A BILL
SEVENTEEN TO READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. GOVERNOR'S
VETOES SHALL BE CONTINUED.
RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEMS ONE
NINETEEN THROUGH ONE TWENTY
THREE I AM SORRY CONSIDERATION
OUR CONTINUED NOW MOVING TO THE
THIRD READING FILE FILE ITEMS
ONE TWENTY FOUR AND ONE TWENTY
FIVE WILL BE PASSED IN RETAINS
FILEITEM ONE TWENTY SIX PASS
TEMPORARILY FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY SEVEN WILL PASS AND
RETAIN MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY EIGHT HR SIXTY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ. HOUSE
RESOLUTION SIXTY NINE BY SOME
REMEMBER THE ROLE RELATIVE TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH. MR ALONE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS
MATTER. THANK YOU MATT AS CHAIR
TODAY I BRING BEFORE YOU HR
SIXTY NINE COMMEMORATING. THE
FORTY SEVENTH ANNIVERSARY OF
THE UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
DECISION IN ROE V. WADE
AFFIRMING EVERY WOMAN HAS THE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO CONTROL
HER OWN REPRODUCTIVE DECISIONS
AND WHETHER TO CONTINUE A
PREGNANT PREGNANCY OR OBTAIN AN
ABORTION. WELL THE WAY IT WAS A
VICTORY FOR WOMEN TO OWN THEIR
OWN BODIES AND LAID THE
GROUNDWORK TO FURTHER
REPRODUCTIVE AND SEXUAL HEALTH
CARE POLICIES THROUGHOUT THIS
COUNTRY. IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
ONE OF TWO STATES WHERE THIS
RIGHT IS PROTECTED IN BOTH
STATUTE AND OUR CONSTITUTION.
HOUSE RESOLUTION SIXTY NINE
SOLIDIFIES THE ASSEMBLY SUPPORT
AND COMMITMENT TO PROTECT
PERSONS FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO
DECIDE IF AND WHEN THEY BECOME
APPARENT. EVEN WITH THESE
PROTECTIONS THE RIGHT TO
ACCESSIBLE XIN SAFELY AND
LEGALLY IN THIS COUNTRY IS IN
JEOPARDY AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND SUPREME COURT
CAN STILL NARAL THESE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS. A
PROTECTIONS GRANTED BY ROE V.
WADE ARE AT THEIR HIGHEST RISK
OF BEING OVERTURNED. AT ALL
LEVELS WHEN WE CONSIDER POLICY
ON WOMEN'S HEALTH WE ALLOW
WOMEN. AND THEIR DOCTORS AND
MEDICAL EXPERTS TO COLLECTIVELY
MAKE A DECISION ABOUT THEIR OWN
BODY. ACCORDING TO A NATIONALLY
REPRESENTATIVE SURVEY CONDUCTED
BY PERRY AND DEM AMERICANS IN
CALIFORNIANS OVERWHELMINGLY
SUPPORT ROE V. WADE DECISION
WITH 72% OF AMERICANS
SUPPORTING ACCESS TO ABORTION.
IT IS VITAL FOR CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS HOME TO NEARLY TWENTY
MILLION WOMEN TO RECOGNIZE AND
UPHOLD THESE FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS
ESPECIALLY DURING A TIME WHEN
PROVIDERS OF REPRODUCTIVE AND
SEXUAL HEALTH CARE LIKE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD ARE UNDER SERIOUS
UNRELENTING ATTACK FOR
PROVIDING SAFE AND LEGAL
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE. I
LIKE MANY OF YOU STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF A WOMAN'S
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT AS CONFIRMED
IN ROE V. WADE TO MAKE THEIR
OWN DECISIONS REGARDING THEIR
PREGNANCY AND URGE FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON HR SIXTY NINE. THANK
YOU MS LIMON. WE'RE GOING OUT
OF HIS BARRICADE IN YOUR
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IS THE
CHAIRPERSON OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON WOMEN'S
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH I RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF HR SIXTY
NINE ON THE EVE OF THE FORTY
SEVENTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
HISTORIC DECISION OF ROE V.
WADE ABORTION ACCESS HAS NEVER
BEEN MORE AT RISK IN THIS
COUNTRY. MY ENTIRE LIFE I HAVE
BEEN PRIVILEGED BY THIS RIGHT
TO PRIVACY. BUT TODAY IT IS AT
RISK. CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS
BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF
ENSURING A WOMAN HAS CHOICES
WHEN IT COMES TO HER PERSONAL
REPRODUCTIVE DECISIONS AND
HEALTH CARE. HOWEVER RIGHT NOW
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SEEKS TO
GAG AND BAN AND REMOVAL CRUCIAL
PATHWAYS FOR CARE FOR WOMEN. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN ALONE OVER
THREE HUNDRED BILLS WERE
INTRODUCED IN WASHINGTON DC AND
STATE HOUSES ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY AIMED AT ELIMINATING
ACCESS TO SAFE LEGAL ABORTION
SERVICES. IT IS INCUMBENT UPON
US IN CALIFORNIA TO PROTECT AND
SECURE OUR FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS
IN LIGHT OF THE CONTINUED
ATTACKS. YOUR MIND IT JUST THIS
WEEKEND AS I MARCHED WITH
THOUSANDS OF OTHER WOMEN IN THE
WOMEN'S MARCH THE POWER THAT WE
HOLD TO MAKE CHANGE WHEN WE
STAND TOGETHER. MY YOUNG
DAUGHTER SAW A SIGN THAT SAID
MY BODY MY CHOICE AND SHE SAID
THAT'S RIGHT MOM MY BODY MY
CHOICE AND TOGETHER WE MUST
PROTECT OUR RIGHTS MOVING
FORWARD. CALIFORNIA WILL
CONTINUE TO BE AT THE FOR. FOR
PROVIDING COPPER CIVICS BOOK
COMPETENT INCOMPLETE CARE FOR
WOMEN. IN THE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH SPACE. BECAUSE THEY ALL
KNOW. REPRODUCTIVE CARE IS
HEALTH CARE. WE ARE FORTUNATE
pCARE CHAMPION THROUGHOUT EACH
LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT OF
CALIFORNIA. MANY OF WHOM ARE IN
THIS ROOM RIGHT NOW. I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HER
COURAGE AND FOR THE TIMELINESS
OF HR SIXTY NINE WHICH
REAFFIRMS THAT EVERY WOMAN HAS
A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO CONTROL
HER OWN REPRODUCTIVE DECISIONS
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. TAKING HIS
DARK MEMBERS ASK YOU GIVE YOUR
IS RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO YOUR
COLLEAGUES AS THEY ADDRESS THIS
BODY MR BONTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA BARBARA
FOR INTRODUCING HOUSE
RESOLUTION SIXTY NINE TO
COMMEMORATE THE FORTY SEVENTH
ANNIVERSARY OF ROE VERSUS WADE.
LAST YEAR OVER THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY ANTI ABORTION BILLS
WERE PASSED IN NUMEROUS
NUMEROUS STATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND THIS FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO
THREATEN WOMEN'S ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES.
I'M PROUD THAT IN CALIFORNIA
WE'RE LEADING THE WAY IN THE
SPACE BY PASSING SOME OF THE
MOST PRO CHOICE MEASURES OF ANY
STATE. WE HAVE DOUBLED OUR
INVESTMENT IN REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS AND CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO SUPPORT LAWS THAT
ENSURE THAT MEDICAL DECISIONS.
ARE MADE BETWEEN A WOMAN AND
HER FAMILY AND HER DOCTOR.
POLITICIANS SHOULD NOT BE
INTERFERING WITH THIS DEEPLY
PERSONAL DECISION. LAST YEAR
GOVERNOR NEWSOME AND THIS
LEGISLATURE WORK TO IMPROVE
ACCESS TO ABORTION SERVICES ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES AN INCREASE-ACCESS TO BIRTH CONTROL THROUGH
TELEHEALTH HOWEVER. MANY LOW
INCOME WOMEN WOMEN OF COLOR
CALIFORNIANS AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND OTHER
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS STILL
STRUGGLE. CALIFORNIA WE WILL
CONTINUE TO PROTECT NOT BàN
THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE ESPECIALLY
FOR THOSE IN OUR COMMUNITY WHO
NEED IT MOST. I'M PROUD TO
STAND AS A LONG TIME ALLY FOR
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON HR SIXTY NINE. THANK
YOU MISTER BONTA IS
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
GOOD MORNING MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF HR IXTY NINE. ON
THE EVE OF THE FORTY SEVENTH
ANNIVERSARY OF ROE VERSUS WADE
I CANNOT HELP BUT THINK ABOUT
WHAT THE BANDS BEING CONSIDERED
ACROSS THE COUNTRY MEAN FOR
WOMEN. MEN AND THEIR FAMILIES.
WHAT IS MOST THE CITY IS ABOUT
THESE EFFORTS IS THE
RESTRICTIONS ON REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE HIT WORKING
FAMILIES THE HARDEST. DON'T
FOOL YOURSELF INTO BELIEVING
THAT THE WEALTHY DON'T EXERCISE
THEIR RIGHTS. THEY JUST DON'T
HAVE TO COUNT ON OTHERS TO HELP
MAKE THOSE DECISIONS ABOUT
THEIR FAMILY'S HEALTH AND
FUTURE. THIS MEANS OF WOMEN OF
COLOR LGBT Q. PEOPLE AND PEOPLE
IN RURAL COMMUNITIES ARE
IMPACTED EVEN MORE. BECAUSE
THEIR ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE IS
ALREADY A CHALLENGE. THANKFULLY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
FOUGHT TO PASS A PROTECT LAWS
THAT ENSURE SAFE LEGAL ABORTION
AND ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH SERVICES. OUR STATE HAS
DOUBLED OUR INVESTMENT IN
SEXUAL REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AND
WE CAN AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
FIGHT YEAR AFTER YEAR TO ENSURE
THAT THIS TREND. CONTINUES TO
EXPAND AND NOT BANNED. I URGE
AN AYE VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
MINS BOERNER HORVATH YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. YES COLLEAGUES I
RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF H. R.
SIXTY NINE. I AS YOU GUYS ALL
KNOW I'M A FIERCE CHAMPION OF
WOMEN'S EQUALITY AND WE KNOW IF
WE DON'T GET TO DECIDE WHEN
UNDER WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES AND
WITH WHOM WE START A FAMILY WE
WILL NEVER BE EQUAL SO I URGE
AN AYE VOTE TODAY ON THIS
REALLY IMPORTANT MEASURE TO
MAKE SURE WE KEEP CALIFORNIA
LEADING ON PROTECTING OUR RIGHT
AND ACCESS TO WOMEN'S HEALTH
CARE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
BOERNER HORVATH MISS WICKS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES. A YEAR
AGO. ON THE ANNIVERSARY OF ROE
V. WADE I STOOD IN FRONT OF
YOU. MY FIRST FLOOR STATEMENT
AS A NEWLY ELECTED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND I TOLD YOU MY STORY
THE STORY OF MY ABORTION. AND
HERE WE ARE A YEAR LATER. SINCE
THEN FIFTY EIGHT ABORTION
RESTRICTIONS HAVE BEEN PASSED
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY IN SOME
PLACES A NEAR COMPLETE. BAN ON
ABORTION. ALABAMA TRIED TO BAN
THE PROCEDURE ALMOST ENTIRELY
LAST YEAR WHEN ITS GOVERNOR
SIGNED A LAW. THAT COULD SLAP
DOCTORS WITH UP TO NINETY NINE
YEARS IN PRISON FOR PERFORMING
AN ABORTIONEVEN IN THE CASE OF
RAPE OR INCEST. A YEAR LATER
HERE WE ARE AGAIN. OHIO GEORGIA
KENTUCKY MISSISSIPPI MISSOURI
AND LOUISIANA HAVE PASSED FEEL
HEART BEAT LAWS BANNING
ABORTIONS AT THE ONSET OF A
FOETAL HEARTBEAT. THIS CAN
OCCUR AS EARLY AS SIX WEEKS
INTO PREGNANCY OFTEN WELL
BEFORE WOMEN EVEN KNOW THEY'RE
PREGNANT. LIKE ALABAMA THE
MISSOURI LAW WOULD ALSO
SEVERELY PENALIZED HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS TRYING TO PROVIDE
WOMEN WITH THE SERVICES OFTEN
LIFE SERVING LIFESAVING THAT
THEY DESERVE. A YEAR LATER HERE
WE ARE AGAIN. AND IN LESS THAN
TWO MONTHS THE SUPREME COURT
WILL HEAR ITS FIRST MAJOR
ABORTION CASE SINCE PRESIDENT
TRUMP APPOINTED TO CONSERVATIVE
JUSTICES. THE OUTCOME COULD
RESHAPE THE FUTURE OF ROE V.
WADE AND ALL THE CONSTITUTIONAL
PRINCIPLES GOVERNING ABORTION
RIGHTS. WE CANNOT SIT BY AND
WATCH THE INTEGRITY OF ROE V.
WADE BE ERODED WE MUSTDO
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN TO STAND
STRONG IN SUPPORT OF EVERY
WOMAN'S FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO
MAKE HER OWN REPRODUCTIVE
DECISIONS. AND I ASK YOU TO
STAND WITH ME TODAY AND SUPPORT
HR SIXTY NINE. BY PRESSING THE
GREEN BUTTON TODAY YOU ARE
STANDING WITH WOMEN WHO LIKE ME
HAVE MADE THIS TOUGH DECISION.
BY PRESSING THE SCREEN BUTTON
YOU ARE ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO BE A
BEACON OF HOPE ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY. I ASK THAT YOU STAY
WITH ME AND MILLIONS OF WOMEN
IN CALIFORNIA ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY AND SUPPORT HR SIXTY
NINE. THANK YOU MISTER X.
MISTER MATHIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS. I RISE TO
SHARE AN ABORTION STORY OF MY
pMY TWINS JEFFERSON AND MAGGIE
AND WHEN MY WIFE WAS PREGNANT.
YOU KNOW YOU WE WENT IN AND WE
GOT THE OLDER SOUND VERY VERY
EARLY ON. AND THEY SPOTTED A
DEFECT. WITH ONE OF THE TWINS
SPINA BIFIDA. SOMETHING THAT
COULD CAUSE DETRIMENTAL HARM TO
THE CHILD. SOMETHING THEY SAID
THIS CHILD MAY NEVER WALK MAY
NEVER CRAWL. MAY NEVER BE ABLE
TO DO ANY OF THESE THINGS. BUT
THE FIRST OPTION THAT WE WERE
GIVEN WAS MR AD MRS MATHIS YOU
KNOW WE CAN GO IN AND ABORT
THAT ONE. AND YOU ALREADY HAVE
ONE CHILD WITH DISABILITIES ARE
YOU SURE YOU WANT ANOTHER. AND
THAT'S A HARD CHOICE IN LIFE IS
ALL ABOUT CHOICES AND ABOUT
MAKING SURE WE HAVE THE
FREEDOMS TO MAKE THOSE CHOICES.
BUT AFTER PRAYER AND AFTER
EVERYTHING WE DECIDED TO CHOOSE
LIFE. IN CHOOSE OUR SON
JEFFERSON WHO MANY OF YOU OF
MATT ON THE FLOOR WHO WAS TOLD.
HE NEVER EVEN BE ABLE TO CRAWL
AND NOW HE RUNS INCLINES IS IN
SCHOOL. AND I JUST COULDN'T
THINK OF A MOMENT WITHOUT THE
ABILITY TO GET AS HE CALLS IT
DADDY CUDDLES. WITH MY SON AND
SO WHAT WE THINK OF THESE
THINGS IT IS ABOUT CHOICES AND
HAVING US FREEDOM OF CHOICES
BUT I ALSO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO THINK ABOUT SOME FOLKS WOULD
PREFER TO CHOOSE LIFE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS
MISTER CHIU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND I
WANT TO THANK OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM FACILITY ABOUT REMINDING
US HOW IMPORTANT IS. THAT ALL
AMERICANS HAVE A RIGHT TO
CHOOSE. AS OPPOSED TO BEING
TOLD WHAT THEIR OPTIONS ARE.
REVIEW WAIT IS IMPORTANT PART
AN IMPORTANT PRINCIPLE OF WHO
WE ARE AS A COUNTRY BUT IT'S
NOT EXAGGERATION. TO SAY THAT
THIS DECISION IS ON THE LINE
LIKE IT'S NEVER BEEN BEFORE
THIS YEAR AND TWENTY TWENTY. AS
WAS ALLUDED TO BY OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM OAKLAND IN MARCH THE
SUPREME COURT WILL HEAR
ARGUMENTS IN JUNE MEDICAL
SERVICES VERSUS G. THE FIRST
MAJOR CHALLENGE TO ABORTION
ACCESS SINCE JUSTICE
KAVANAUGH'S CONFIRMATION TO THE
SUPREME COURT. THE CASE
CONCERNED A LOUISIANA LAW
THAT'S IDENTICAL TO A TEXAS
LAW. THAT THE SUPREME COURT
STRUCK DOWN JUST A MERE FOUR
YEARS AGO. THE ONLY THING
THAT'S CHANGED SINCE THAT
DECISION AND TWENTY SIXTEEN IS
A COMPOSITION OF THE COURT. THE
STAKES COULD NOT BE HIGHER. IF
THE SUPREME COURT UPHOLDS A
pLONGER BE A SINGLE ABORTION
PROVIDER IN THAT STATE. THE
EFFECT OF WHICH IS THE SAME AS
OUTLINED ABORTION ALTOGETHER
AND THIS IS THE POINT FOR ANTI
CHOICE FORCES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WHO ARE HOPING TO GOT
ROVI WAY TO THE EXTENT TO
WHICH- IT IS SIMPLY A RIGHT IN
NAME ONLY. AND UNFORTUNATELY
THERE ARE ALL MAKERS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WHO ARE ASKING THE
COURTTO GO EVEN FARTHER. THIS
MONTH MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
ANTI CHOICE LAWMAKERS IN
CONGRESS SIGNED ONTO AN AMICUS
BRIEF URGING THE COURT TO
RECONSIDER ROE. ON THIS FORTY
SEVENTH ANNIVERSARY OF ROE WE
NEED TO BE MORE VIGILANT THAN
EVER. SUPPORT FOR THE SUPREME
COURT CASE IS AT AN ALL TIME
HIGH WITH 77% OF ALL AMERICANS
SUPPORTING THIS CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
ALL STAND UP TO GUARANTEE. THAT
TWENTY TWENTY DOES NOT MARK THE
REAL LAST ANNIVERSARY OF ROE V.
WADE AND WITH THAT RESPECT WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHIU SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MISS THE MON YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND I
WANNA THANK ALL MY CALL.
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR COMMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT THE FIRST
ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS AND
I THINK ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES
FOR A STRONG COMMITMENT. TO
PROTECTING CHOICE FOR WOMEN IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU MISTER
MON THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
RIVER FIRST ROLE FOR CO
AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
MEMBERS. ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS I
READ THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESERVE IT THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE
THERE FIFTY THREE CO AUTHORS ON
HR SIXTY NINE WE WILL MOVE TO A
ROLL CALL VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS SAID WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW IT ABOUT AYE AYES FIFTY
FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN HR SIXTY
NINE IS ADOPTED. MOVING BACK UP
TO FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY SIX A.
B. SIXTEEN THIRTY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME MIDDLE
SIXTEEN THIRTY FIVE BY SOME
REMEMBER GREAT ACTUALLY NORSE
RACING. MR GRAY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THE MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY FIVE MANAGES
RACING DATES AT VENUE STRUCK
CALIFORNIA- APPRECIATE YOUR-
AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE TODAY.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED AS ARE THE- ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS VERY VOTE.
WORK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN
NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY NINE WILL
PASS AND RETAIN MOVING TO FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY AB FIFTEEN OH
SIX THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
PEOPLE FIFTEEN OH SIX BY SOME
MEMBER MCCARTY INOCULATE A
SOLID WASTE NUCLEAR YEARS ZERO
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY MR
MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THE MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER THIS IS A CLEAN IT
BUILT TO LAST YEAR'S GREEN
RESTAURANT RECYCLING BILL.
HELPING CLARIFY FOR AMUSEMENT
PARKS THAT THEY HAVE WHEN THEY
HAVE MOBILE FOOD SERVICE
ENTITIES THROUGHOUT THEIR PARK
THEY WOULD NOT HAVE TO COMPLY
WITH THESE RULES BUT WOULD HAVE
TO HAVE A COMPATIBLE PROCESS
FOR THEIR- PHYSICAL RESTAURANTS
THROUGHOUT THE- MUSIC PARK. ASK
THE ARRIVAL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER MCCARTY SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED THIRTY VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE AYE SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO ON THE MEASURE I SIXTY
SEVEN NOTES HERE ON THE URGENCY
THIS MEASURE PASSES. WE WILL
PASS A RETAIN AND FILE ITEMS
ONE THIRTY ONE THREE ONE THIRTY
FOUR WILL PASS A ROUTINE ON
THIRD READING SENATE BILLS FILE
ITEMS ONE THIRTY FIVE AND ONE
THIRTY SIX. MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS TODAY IS
OUR COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA AS BIRTHDAY PLEASE JOIN
ME IN WISHING HIM A HAPPY
BIRTHDAY. THIS SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS WEDNESDAY JANUARY
TWENTY SECOND CHECK IN SESSION
THURSDAY JANUARY TWENTY THIRD
WE HAVE FLOOR SESSION AT NINE
AM. IN THE ABSENCE OF AN
OBJECTION WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED THE
GERMANS AND MEMORIES. WITHOUT
OBJECTION QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF THE FLOOR OR TAKE YOUR
SEATS MEMBERS.
WE WILL
ENTERTAIN VOTE CHANGES AT THIS
TIME MISTER BLOOM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR ABOUT CHANGE
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I'LL BE
TAKING MY VOTE ON THAT AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY FIVE FROM- I TO.
NOT VOTING. BEAU CHANGE SOME
REMEMBER BLOOM ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN THIRTY FIVE I TO NOT
VOTING.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON AN INJURY MEMORY MR
MAYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY. THE
MEDICINE BEAKER. AND MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE WITH A HEAVY HEART
TO MEMORIALIZE THE PASSING OF
RICHARD ROY ALL FUN THE SECOND.
RICH WAS A LIFELONG RESIDENT OF
THE COACHELLA VALLEY WHO HAD
INTERESTS AS DIVERSE AS THE
VALLEY ITSELF. IS INSATIABLE
LOVE OF LIFE LED HIM TO BECOME
FATHER A BUILDER A TALENTED
MUSICIAN TO GET THE
PHOTOGRAPHER AND AWARD WINNING
VIDEOGRAPHER A WRITER A GOLFER
AND EVEN AN AIR AIRPLANE PILOT.
BEAUTY SURROUNDS ALL OF US IN
LIFE AND RICH KNEW THAT BETTER
THAN MOST. HE FOUND THAT SET UP
THE SOLIDARITY AND SERENDIPITY
OF NATURE THERAPEUTIC I WAS
PART OF A RARE BREED OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO COULD CAPTURE
IT BEHIND THE LENS OF A CAMERA.
CREATIVITY FLOWED FREELY FROM
RICH AS A MUSICIAN HE WAS ABLE
TO PICK UP SEEMINGLY ANY
INSTRUMENT. AND WRITE A NEW
SONG. THE SUCCESSES OF HIS
PROFESSIONAL CAREER WERE
EQUALLY IMPRESSIVE. WHAT THE
MAJORITY OF HIS WORK WAS
FOCUSED ON THE PRODUCTION OF
MEDICAL EDUCATION VIDEOS. HE
FOUND SUCCESS PRODUCING TRAVEL
DOCUMENTARIES FOR THE
GOVERNMENTS OF THAILAND. INDIA
AND CHINA AND WAS THE FIRST NON
CHINESE AND NOT NATIONAL
ALLOWED TO FILM THE TERRACOTTA
ARMY. THIS BODY AND THE
COMMUNITIES OF THE COACHELLA
VALLEY MOURN THE LOSS OF THIS
OUTSTANDING INDIVIDUAL. WE CAN
TAKE SOLACE IN HIS CAN IN HIS
CONTINUE MEMORY. I AM GRATEFUL
THAT THE OPPORTUNE TO HONOR HIM
AND WITH THAT MISTER SPEAKER. I
WOULD LIKE TO JOIN THE MEMBER
GIVE RICHARD WRIGHT OFF AND THE
SECOND. THANK YOU MISTER MAYES
MISTER MEDINA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS. TODAY I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF MELBA
DUNLAP. MOBILE WAS A CLOSE
FRIEND AND A FORMER SECOND
DISTRICT SUPERVISOR WHO PASSED
AWAY ON MONDAY JANUARY
THIRTEENTH. MOBILE WAS EIGHTY
EIGHT YEARS OLD AND SERVED ON
THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS FROM NINETEEN
EIGHTY THREE TO NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE. SHE WAS THE ONLY THE
SECOND FEMALE ELECTED TO THE
RIVERSIDE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
NUMBER WAS A PASSIONATE LEADER
MENTOR AND ROLE MODEL WHO
ALWAYS WANTED TO IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR ALL OF
RIVERSIDE. SHE WAS BORN ON
MARCH NINTH NINETEEN THIRTY ONE
IN HIGGINS TEXAS AND MOVED TO
RIVERSIDE IN NINETEEN FIFTY
EIGHT. WHEN HER HUSBAND EUGENE
DUNLAP WAS STATIONED AT MARCH
AIR FORCE RESERVE BASE. THEY
WERE MARRIED FOR SIXTY THREE
YEARS AND LIVE MOST OF THEIR
LIFE IN THE CITY OF RIVERSIDE
WHERE THEY RAISE FOUR CHILDREN.
HAVING LIVED IN THE AREA FOR
SIX DECADES SHE EXPERIENCE THE
RAPID GROWTH OF RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND FOR SOPHOMORE ON THE
HORIZON. ALBERT SERVED ON THE
CITIZENS TRANSPORTATION
ADVISORY COMMITTEE NOW KNOWN AS
THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION. SHE
HELPED START THE COUNTIES FURS
BUS SYSTEM WHICH IS NOW KNOWN
AS THE RIVERSIDE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY. SHE WAS A FOUNDING
MEMBER OF THE WESTERN REGIONAL
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS AND IN
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE SHE
RECEIVED THE PATRICIA ANN
WILSON OUTSTANDING COMMUNITY
SERVICE AWARD FROM THAT
ORGANIZATION. MR DUNLAP SERVER
IS SURVIVED BY THREE OF HER
FOUR CHILDREN JAMES DUNLAP
MALINA BIG B. AND DAVID DUNLAP
SHE IS ALSO SURVIVED BY THREE
GRANDCHILDREN AND TWO GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN BROADER MUCH JOY.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING IN MEMORY
OF MEL THE DEADLINE. THANK YOU
MISTER MEDINA MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAME SUGGEST WE
PRINTED THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUESTS TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL. ALL OTHER ITEMS
MEETING WILL BE PASSED IN
RETAINED ALMOST AS SHALL BE
CONTINUED. SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MR BONTA MOVED TO MISTER
CUNNINGHAM SECONDS AT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
THURSDAY JANUARY TWENTY THIRD
AT NINE AM.